we love celebrating any national holiday
especially with so many
that involves champagne absolutely may
16th marks national mimosa day so
jillian joins us live from the chayo at
the link promenade and to show us how
they're planning to celebrate and look
she's already oh she's partaking already
cheers jillian
cheers i started the celebrations early
we like to say that every day should be
national mimosa day it's technically
coming up on monday but we're here at
child we moved a little bit down the
promenade here at the link i'm joined by
tanya first off cheers cheers cheers
hold up oh you have a beautiful cocktail
well cheers to beautiful weather
delicious food we're here at chayo let's
talk about some of the specials that
they have going on and you can enjoy
mimosas bottomless whenever you want
that's right bottomless mimosas here at
chiyo every day not just national mimosa
day which again every day should be
from 9 a.m to 1 p.m along with all kinds
of wonderful food items from breakfast
foods the churro french toast all the
way over to the nachos and everything
else that we have here yeah we were
hanging out with brandon earlier he's
telling me about all of these food items
we have out here i kind of got lost in
the churro french toast with their steak
chilaquiles chicken nachos yeah and
enchiladas shrimp tacos i think i got
them all right and it's just so fun out
here the weather is beautiful let's talk
a little bit about the promenade overall
why it's just such a fun place to hang
out you know the promenade is las vegas
strip it's busy it has that vibe but it
also is a little bit on the calmer side
we have beautiful patios we have a
fountain lots of beautiful trees so it's
like being in las vegas without quite
being in las vegas if that makes sense
very very calm like i said a lot of
beautiful patios with all kinds of
amazing food and amazing drinks
throughout yeah i feel like i'm on
vacation when i'm hanging out here the
music was playing everyone's having a
good time and you know as you're sitting
here the people are zip lining over us
you can go on the high roller there's a
little bit of something here at the
promenade and tanya i'm sorry i can't
just stand here and not eat something so
what do you say should i go in for the
nachos i think so it's not true it's
mimosa time and nacho time well it's
always again almost the time at night
always a good time these are loaded i
feel like this is going to end in a
really messy bite here on live tv so
i'll i'll finish it here in a second
just really quickly one more time let's
remind everyone how they can celebrate
national mimosa day at chiyo absolutely
please come in to child come visit us at
the promenade like you said zipline high
roller all kinds of amazing stores and
restaurants and we love to have locals
and we love to have visitors from across
the world well tanya thank you for
having us i definitely will be hanging
out celebrating i'm going in for the
nacho i'll send it back to you guys oh
thank you jillian i am kind of jealous
right now i wish i was
at that table